[Music]
this is StarTalk sports edition and this
time we're doing a cosmic queries grab
bag got with me Chuck O'Reilly
Chuck Nice
you just Just Married us yes
I had to take Gary's name what does that
mean look nice
I think of you as my one common
conjoined co-host I'm sorry so Chuck
Nice good to have you there man yes Dr
Frankenstein good to be here all right
Gary O'Reilly former footballer from the
UK and broadcaster yes
of him for us very good to have you this
is a grab bag and anytime we have a grab
bag this is like the batch signal going
up into the clouds we got to reach for
our geek in Chief the one the only okay
hold your applause till the end
a friend and colleague uh astrophysicist
Charles Liu who's a professor of
astronomy and physics at the City
University of New York in Staten Island
and and always good to have you here
you're a fan favorite and so you're
going to help us in this grab bag I mean
I might be able to do some but when it
comes to really geeky answers to cool
questions I am unworthy and I will just
sit back oh Neil you don't have to say
that but I'm happy to be here it's
always fun so and and the questions are
always the best they're always cool
they're always cool so Gary Chuck you
got questions lined up
yes uh right let's start with um one of
our very favorites and I can't do the
voice anywhere near
the ability to Chuck has but it's
Alejandro no no give it a check why are
you reading it they're chuck
chuck oh I I didn't know we were
starting here so
I gotta I gotta go pull up I gotta pull
up Alejandro pull up the message so
again all of our uh all of our Cosmic
queries today are exclusively asked by
patreon members with our new entry level
category we have five dollars a month so
you can't argue with that all right here
we go let's start it off with our friend
Alejandro
straight up
Alejandro Reynoso who comes to us from
Monterey Mexico and he says hello
or should I say hola
[Laughter]
my question is how do you think we can
use artificial intelligence in exploring
the universe
so there it is so so Charles Lou what do
you have to say about Ai and our field
Alejandro let me tell you you are right
on the mark and in fact we are already
trying to do precisely this
um as many of you know I am part of the
cosmos collaboration working with the
James Webb Space Telescope Neil you're
familiar with that uh yeah back when we
were working on it with just the Hubble
Space Telescope data right but now we
have a James Webb Space Telescope the
cosmos collaboration is a Consortium of
people and institutions that have
targeted sections of the sky just to
hammer it as with as many kinds of
telescopic observations and detectors as
possible to learn pra basically
everything knowable about sections of
the sky that we target so continue so
now we've applied this to the James Webb
so what do you have really right well
the James Webb Space Telescope first
Seasons uh most significant observing
project is to use the James Webb to aim
at the cosmos field which you described
so aptly just a few seconds ago and so
we are spending 270 hours of James Webb
time in just a small patch of Sky about
the size of your pinky fingernail
and as a result of length yeah
when you're looking up at the sky
at arm's length yeah yeah nut finger in
your eyeball right right yeah that would
be difficult so so there's literally
terabytes and terabytes worth of data
coming from all the different
observatories around the world and James
Webb is just let layering on that next
layer of information about this patch of
sky and no human being can individually
process all of that information in any
meaningful way in a human lifetime so
what we need instead is the opportunity
to use machines machine learning deep
learning artificial intelligence to help
us make sense of all of this incredible
amount of information so for example we
had information about possibly 2 million
or so galaxies within this Cosmos field
ranging all the way out to 13 and a half
billion light years away just to be
clear this fingernail at arms length
blots out 2 million galaxies right on
the sky that is correct to the edge of
these numbers okay right so mad oh okay
I'm sorry
no I'm just trying to get there okay I I
just thought of something that's a whole
nother question I'm not going to screw
us up and get us off track
remember you're not allowed to ask
questions okay you have five bucks on
you wait hold on let me
do you take credit cards
what's the expiry
so each of these two million galaxies
has thousands of pieces of information
about it that have been gathered by all
these telescopes that have been trained
on it for the past 20 years off and on
and now we've added James Webb on top
can we make a pattern can we understand
what actually matters can we ask
ourselves
can we look at all two millimeters
galaxies and find something new actually
probably not but using artificial
intelligence we can do that we can say
here are the parameters of what we think
are normal
can you please find for us all the
normal things and then all the abnormal
things and then tell us what is normal
and what is abnormal or in between right
and what should we be looking at that
allows us to sort of understand the
change of the galaxies in the universe
from 13 billion years ago to the present
day I mean that's a heady question which
any individual human can sort of grab
the most creative and interesting ways
but processing all of that information
AI is the answer we're not there yet so
Charles why isn't this why is it why
isn't this just more powerful Computing
rather than what people generally today
think of as AI great because we've we've
always wanted we've always treated
computers ever since computers have been
brought to our our field to we've needed
it to to reduce and analyze massive
amounts of data even when massive
amounts of data in the day was only a
kilobyte or you know or megabyte yeah so
now we're up to terabytes so isn't it
just more powerful Computing number
crunching question as opposed to
thinking great yes it's really thinking
number crunching has been going up it
actually is extremely important and
you're right that's most of what
computers are doing for us in astronomy
today but it's that next step I think it
started maybe three or four years ago
that we really started shifting over
toward machine learning and artificial
intelligence so both are still working
hand in hand together and you know in in
the current circumstance the AI part is
still in its infancy a lot of times when
people publish scientific results that
they found using AI or machine learning
they're probably not right uh but we
publish them anyway because we say hey
it might be right please let us let the
rest of us colleagues go back and check
to see if what this machine found is
actually something in reality the
all-important verification step that's
right right so compare all of that to
neural Nets
well neural net is just another way that
we can
abstractly map the idea of intelligence
and pattern recognition right right
current because we think that's our
brain works as we say neural right
that's right just the connectivity to
following patterns and and whatever it
is that might manifest that's right uh
the neural net itself is a pretty
complicated thing but we can strip it
down to very basic components and say
can you do a one-dimensional or
two-dimensional a three-dimensional
discussion about all this information
try to make connections that otherwise
wouldn't be able to see if we were just
trying to use one CPU by itself you know
one brain or one Processing Unit
um the neural Nets in our brains are not
just three-dimensional they're four five
six ten you know each uh neuron attaches
in many unusual ways to many others so
there's a sort of an emergence of
awareness that comes about from you how
these networks of that kind of
complexity so these are the things I I
think you did a cosmos episode on this
right Neil once yeah about how
intelligence and the concept of a very
complicated neural net like a human
brain can actually be more complicated
than even an entire galaxy worth of
stars and their interactions and so
forth it's very very powerful but orally
understood all right yeah are we looking
for the right things I mean using AI
obviously should be an advantage but are
we looking for the right because this
must be things out there we don't know
exist but we should be looking for but
we don't know to look for them is AI
going to be able to assist in Us in that
kind of capture of data in other words
can it discover what it's not looking
for right thank you it can it can
discover what it's not looking for
that's a great question it can discover
what it's not looking for if we tell it
to look for things that it's not looking
for right so in a sense uh your your
number crunching right data reduction or
say computational work that will give
you the answers to things that you are
looking for now you tell a machine and
say these are what we are looking for
can you tell us any exceptions to what
we found so anything it would have to be
something anomalous but wouldn't you
have to program the parameters of what
an anomaly is no no you only have to
know what we're familiar with and
anything that well anything else
so okay so that means it well that is
kind of that's the easiest part of the
easiest part of the job if it doesn't
fit stick it in it right it goes oh
that's odd okay now let's look at that
the search for outliers in fact 60 years
ago one of our colleagues did that he
looked at all these beautiful galaxies
in the night sky it was a beautiful
spiral and a beautiful elliptical shaped
Galaxy who ordered this one which was
Tangled and mangled and he made a
catalog of just the Tangled mangled
looking galaxies and it was called the
atlas of peculiar galaxies and it was
just it was the catch Basin of nothing
that fit anything else and it and
Charles you remember it became one of
the most studied catalogs in the Canon
of cosmology Alton C ARP chip Arps Atlas
A peculiar galaxies published in 1966.
yes tremendously interesting and what it
was was it turned out that chip arp's
ideas of why they looked peculiar were
incorrect but by putting them together
into a catalog people could look at them
and start wondering and thinking about
what actually was going on and it helped
us understand that galaxies Collide that
they crash into each other and they
create amazing structures which we could
not have imagined had they not collided
and that led to the entire field of
computational astrophysics as applied to
galaxies and by the way we needed the
computers to make that happen so that
was in the 1970s computing power Rose to
then say well I wonder what a Galaxy
would look like if it collided with
another galaxy hey that matches arp's
catalog number 32.3 and and then you and
then you look at it at a different angle
that's a different object in the catalog
and so all of a sudden we don't explain
all the galaxies just as witnesses to
train wrecks you guys keep saying
Collide when you say galaxies Collide is
it that the galaxies
gravity affects another Galaxy's gravity
or are you looking at actual
objects hitting one another because
aren't galaxies so spread out what is it
what's an actual Collision look on the
case what a beautiful question beautiful
beautiful question
when galaxies collide
when galaxies collage that's a movie
title right there we need that one
they uh they do the stars are so far
apart that they almost never hit each
other directly so it's like swarms of
bees uh Hornets you know nests Wings
rats through one another and affecting
one another from a distance okay but uh
a collision doesn't have to happen only
uh when a physical object hits another
physical object what you said the
gravitational effect of one object
affecting the other is indeed as much of
a collision uh as we might think of say
two vehicles hitting one another or
something and so instead you get these
twists and turns you get bends you get
loops and whirls and it is all
gravitational yes indeed so yeah so we
counted a gravitational encounter as a
collision because they affect each other
but I I've Quantified this B analogy so
if there were four bumblebees
flying randomly across the continental
United States
the chances of them accidentally bumping
into one another is the same as two
stars colliding in a in a in two
galaxies uh in an encounter so yeah
basically two stars are not going to
physically Collide but they'll all feel
each other's gravity and that's enough
to make a train wreck so and a beautiful
train wreck they can be these kinds of
train wrecks cause the formation of new
stars new planets uh sometimes in the
billions at a time they feed
supermassive black holes they create
quasars and active nuclei they're one of
the most important engines of the
evolution of the universe itself
wow look at that we gotta take a quick
break when we come back more Cosmic
queries grab back we'll be right back
we're back StarTalk sports edition
Cosmic queries grab bag with our geek in
Chief Charles Lou all right and of
course Chuck and Gary what so what give
me some more questions we're on a roll
here okay
um this one I think is pretty topical so
this is from Samuel Fairchild greetings
from San Antonio Texas
what can we learn from The Runaway
supermassive black hole that was spotted
by the Hubble telescope trailing a 200
000 light year-long tale of new star
formations
um answers please oh it is most likely
a classic example of what happens when
galaxies Collide when galaxies Collide
yeah lots of things can happen so far
away no they couldn't be far away we
hope they're far away but they could be
close by remember in a few billion years
the Andromeda galaxy will collide with
the Milky Way then we'll have a close-up
view of what happens when galaxies
Collide so the story is this right you
have a Galaxy and it's about a hundred
thousand light years across here comes
another galaxy that's also a hundred
thousand light years across they hit
each other at just the right angle and
you can pull
trail of gas outward a couple hundred
thousand light years long wow when that
happens you're basically creating a
stream of new stars forming all along
this Trail
and so there's your 200 000 light years
long trail of new stars form meanwhile
part of that collusion could have hit
and you know there are many different
ways galaxies can Collide but perhaps at
just the right angle and at just the
right speed the supermassive black hole
in one of those galaxies
got stripped out of the body of the
galaxies that are colliding so whereas
the rest of the Galaxy's material is
sort of coalescing into a single blob
that supermassive black hole is out on a
trajectory that looks like it's
following that gas going outward there's
a lot of possibilities and we've only
just begun to figure out what's going on
and by the way is the gas unlike the
Stars the gas doesn't really pass
through itself when the gas collides it
it'll it's like two hot marshmallows
sticking so a lot of interesting things
can happen right on the gas part of the
colliding galaxies yes separate from the
Stars right you can often think of the
gas in a galaxy like the water in a
swimming pool or something they they
have a dissipative force they are
viscous even though they're very sparse
by Earth standards they wind up out in
space sort of along the millions of
years type time scales and the millions
of light years type size scales acting
very similarly to what you might expect
so Charles I did an episode of Nova
science now once where it was exactly
that reference I was at a swimming pool
and I had a I I had a bucket if I
remember this correctly I think I had a
bucket of ping pong balls and so did
someone else and we tossed them towards
each other and only a few of the ping
pong balls hit would hit each other but
then we had buckets of water through the
buckets of water at each other and the
water just like it it was there that you
said fantastic yeah it was fun and we
did it in slow-mo and you can see it it
was pretty cool all right next question
up is from MO
Moe Aloha Neil and Chuck what evidence
can you provide to show that we aren't
in a simulation aren't are not oh
interesting okay proving the negative
can you prove
here's the story right I have an attempt
at it but going on I want to hear what
yes
Linda Descartes hundreds of years ago
right the guy who you know after whom
we've named the Cartesian coordinate
plane but also a great philosopher a
rationalist of his time right right
basically therefore I am yes yes that's
right and he basically set out the idea
that if there were a simulation that was
good enough we would not be able to tell
there's just no philosophical way to
tell as long as the simulation is good
enough so the only evidence that we can
give that we are in a simulation is if
somehow we see a glitch
you may remember the movie Inception uh
when the people in the dreams were
trying to figure out whether or not they
were in reality or not in a reality and
one particular person figured out that
he was in a dream because the texture of
the carpet was different from what he
remembered in reality
right so every single piece of evidence
out in the universe has to be consistent
with what we think is real right and if
not if there's a glitch then we're in a
simulation we can also go to the Matrix
and talk about that okay and how you
when okay yeah the reason they were able
to know they were in a simulation was
because something just didn't happen
correctly that's the only way according
to Descartes that we can prove that we
are in a simulation but how can we prove
we're not in one you just have to keep
looking for the glitches
oh wow look at that but so if if we
don't find any glitches we're either not
in a simulation or it's a perfect
simulation and therefore what's the
point of even distinguishing the correct
okay so with that
with that lineup with paranormal
activities
outing as a glitch
so paranormal activities are not you
know following the laws of nature or
physics or what have you with that count
as a truck
let's say that what are we called
definition or
a miracle a miracle is something that
happens outside of the laws of physics
Miracles and paranormal activity at this
point in our understanding of the
universe our only things that we don't
understand yet there's nothing that's
been shown to be conclusively
a violation of the laws of physics just
something that we haven't explained the
rest of physics yet
Jesus walking on Border moderates a ton
of a ton of laws of physics right there
if that actually happened
in all in all defense he has some really
good sandals okay
he got Jesus said right now okay so so
we all have to think about these
questions uh as skeptically and as
optimistically as we can at the same
time right okay I gotta add another
another pop culture reference sure my
single favorite episode of the two and a
half Seasons or whatever it was a Black
Mirror was the episode titled hang the
DJ which has nothing to do with the
entire story uh it's the name of the
song that you hear at the end in that
it's a dating
Community you go you date multiple
people to see who when you like and then
at the end you get married to them and
we learn should I give it away I have to
give it away otherwise I can't talk
about it we learned that all the people
in this story are being simulated but
you don't know this because you're with
them and they're testing their dating
and oh that didn't work out let's date
another I got to stay three months with
this person it's all prescribed and it's
all do it and they hate each other or
they love each other whatever and what
are the people one of the women who
likes skipping rocks skipped rocks and
said
you know every time I skip rock it only
skips three times
some Should Skip One and some Should
Skip four she just she just tossed it up
and you don't even know to pay attention
to that when that's happening all right
these are characters that have their own
sense of Free Will and one of them
noticed that every time she skipped
rocked it was exactly and identically
three times and we later learned that
all of these people are a simulation so
that when at the end you emerge and the
two people they escape the the simula
they escape this place and as they
escape you see the digitization of
things happening and the next scene are
two people meeting up in a bar who are
matched by that simulation it was like
it's the ultimate swipe left
right yes yeah yeah so the simulation
tested everybody's compatibilities and
it was like oh my but in it was that one
observation so ever since then and a
little bit before then I've been
checking for things that maybe should
have different kind of variation than
what should that's interesting about the
carpet though Charles yeah do we then
project
I'll desire to find a glitch into our
thinking and observations yes without
question Gary that's a great points we
humans are biased in One Direction or
another in general right yeah and and
just like it's very hard for all of us
to be rational all the time and maybe we
shouldn't be the circumstance is of our
detecting whether we're in a simulation
or not are almost secondary in
importance to whether or not we are in
whatever environment we are it's real or
simulated and live the way we want to
live and do the things we want to do so
in my recent book story messenger I
reflect on what a simulated world would
be and I use that as evidence that we're
not in a simulated world you know what
it is a simulated world is created by
computers and computers are absolutely
logical
and scope
no
set of computers would ever create the
world we live in
so it's the inanity defense it's like
Earth is inane in every way computers
have higher Integrity than that even in
a population that's my evidence that's
great evidence except that you may be
putting too much stock in our inanity it
may well be that inanity is an inherent
part of logical systems
would a computer be able to generate or
recreate love
easily
depends on what you think love is I got
that this is where I'm past that okay so
so watch watch you get everybody who's
in love with something or some other
person right and then you do a brain
scan and I'm making this up but it's
plausible you do a brain scan and
everyone has the same part of their
brain lit up right while they have these
feelings of love right then you take
someone who doesn't have those areas of
the brain lit up and show them something
that's completely neutral right like a
book just a book cover or something then
you light up that part of their brain
and see if they fall in love with the
book and if they do we know exactly what
love is it's the neurosynaptic of this
section of the brain there it is and we
can create it for you if you wanted
if two people are long marriage and
they're falling out of love go back and
re-stimulate they're back in love if
they like Newlyweds
I mean Paul clearly love is a
neurochemical synaptic function of the
brain yes I mean it is it just has to be
on a biological level otherwise you know
I mean you can attach ethereal uh
qualities to it yes but I mean people
who if you don't have if you are brain
dead you can't be in love right here in
fact you don't have to be fully brain
dead you can be partly brain dead in
that section that would matter in that
category right but sometimes it makes no
sense no no way as a matter of fact we
have people who are incapable of Love
okay we call them sociopaths yes and
they're capable of of empathy yes
capable of everything but you have to
have empathy to have love so imagine
imagine a person all right so it does
not imagine a person that is somehow
perhaps what we might call defective and
unable to experience empathy or love the
this person carefully studies thousands
of people who are happily in love
figures out all the behaviors that are
observable from an outside person of how
to be a person who expresses and shows
love and then just
mimics all those behaviors beautifully
running into a person or choosing a
person to treat that person that way to
work with that person that way to do the
things with that person that all those
other people would love her behaving is
that person exhibiting love to another
person
that's why we go inside your brain with
the brain scan that's what my point is
for that's the whole point of the brain
scan if you don't have that part of the
brain lit up but you behave as if that
part of the brain were lit up obviously
you're not alone behaving with love so
I'm going away from a utilitarian
standpoint no you are not because the
only reason you would do that is because
somehow you're being served otherwise
you would not be a sociopath you would
actually be exhibiting love itself right
right perhaps your definition of
behaving in a way that's self-serving is
to behave in a way that everybody else
in the world looks to you as if you are
in love but then are you you may not be
from your brain's point of view that's
why I introduced that's why I introduce
you science here where you go inside the
brain but the point of that I'm asking
you a different kind of science from the
observable perspective
assuming no hidden variables okay
assuming that the interior of the brain
is unknowable I'm not have to assume
something that's not true but
Quantum Mechanics for example suggest
that indeed there are things about
particles at certain levels which are
not observable and I agree but we're
talking about your brain and not a
particle can your brain behave in that
way if
the brain were considered not something
that you can poke in prod what if love
in fact does not light up the same part
of your brain all right when we come
back more start talk sports edition
Cosmic queries with our geek and chief
Charles Lou we'll be right back
we're back start talking sports edition
Cosmic queries grab bag The Geek in
Chief Charles Luke Charles how do we
find you on the internet oh well uh at
Chuck Liu
c-h-u-c-k-l-i-u on Twitter and at the
universe
t-h-e-l-i-u and i v e r s e uh on a wide
variety of platforms the luniverse yeah
podcast is going wherever you get your
podcasts uh we had lots of conversation
fun with that yeah all right cool cool
and Chuck nice you're still Chuck Nice
comic everywhere sir thank you
everywhere cool cool Gary are you still
three left feet Yes I am on Twitter on
Twitter all right my three left feet my
three left feet got it sorry sorry so uh
we got more questions here bring it on
we have right Matt Berg says hello from
Sheboygan Falls I believe that's
Wisconsin
you're welcome uh I have used many of
your discussions in my classroom to have
my middle school students think a bit
deeper about things teacher in the house
all right excellent is simple so here we
go pay attention is this sit comfortably
sit up straight uh is there a simple way
to ever do that in school what are you
talking about stop now is there a simple
way to explain to students what our
universe is expanding into in other
words if the big bang theory created
everything in our universe does that
mean that there has to be something
outside of our universe or how can there
be a nothing that is being expanded into
at the moment at this moment this uh
gentleman Matt Berg his mind starts to
hurt
that's not so bad that's not that's all
the great question and in fact I'll just
have you know that a friend of mine who
is a doctor graduated from IB League
school in Stanford and stuff asked me
that very same question not that long
ago so you are in good company uh Mr
Berg
here's the my way of explaining it
you are at the center of the universe
right now when we make measurements and
try to figure out where the center of
the universe was that it was expanding
out of it always goes to you
whoever is observing observes that they
are the center of the universe
so in other words we are part of the big
bang when the universe was
microscopically Tiny that is what has
become us today there's no central point
because we are at the center the center
just happens to have gotten really
really big that's one way of thinking
about where the center of the universe
is you are the center of the universe
I'm sure your mom told you that at one
time or another or you thought this over
that at one time or another one shows
you that that's right in fact so what
are we expanding into because that's
what it started the expansion into you
can think of as a different dimension
you can think of it as a say
space being
three-dimensional length width and
height expanding into a fourth dimension
which is yes with the fourth dimension
of space which is not linked with their
height or you can actually think of it
as a four-dimensional space time where
the expansion direction is in time you
know where T equals zero at Time Zero is
the Big Bang the universe is very small
and now time has gone on T is about 13.8
billion years and now the universe has
expanded in that fourth dimension of
time you can find lots of different ways
of thinking about it that are
mathematically equivalent so maybe if
you're not like exactly getting the way
that I'm describing it maybe the way
that you foresee it or think about it or
Envision it is just as mathematically
valid as the way that I'm talking about
it right now
wow that's uh that was elegant Charles I
got to give it to you that was I I can't
take credit for that really cool well
thank you Chuck but um you know remember
I I didn't come up with this right our
uh scientific uh forebears you know have
been working on this for a long time and
when they first came up with these ideas
they were hard-pressed to explain them
and understand them because they're so
different from what we thought about
when we were in those times so I'm just
I like that I like to add to it that you
can have a Multiverse where everybody's
expanding but if you're embedded in a
higher Dimension then you will not
necessarily Collide even if you can go
to Infinity so if you if you take a
sheet of paper and send it to Infinity
in every directions so it's an
infinitely large sheet of paper now I
can take another sheet of paper lift it
off of that into a higher Dimension a
third dimension right right and now it's
just quote parallel to the other one
that can go to infinity and never
intersect the other sheet and I can do
that into Infinity through Infinity
and beyond infinity and beyond yeah
so all right so if you embed our three
dimensions into a higher Dimension you
can expand higher dimensions and then
they'll never Collide if they're all in
a dimension yet higher than themselves
so yeah it's amazing so what else we got
there's a Gary or Chuck who's got the
next question
you want another one just like the other
one bring it on um all right partic
Karthik is from Germany if the Earth's
magnetic field is caused by the iron
inner core rotating within the magma
outer core how does gas giant planets
like Jupiter also have a magnetic field
do we know anything about the
composition of the interior of the gas
giants we do
and the answer we think at this moment
is that far enough down in a gas giant
like Jupiter
the hydrogen which we think of as a gas
turns into a metal
it becomes what we call metallic
hydrogen and so you have a core of metal
of conducting stuff that can swirl just
like the core of metal in the earth and
that's how you can get a magnetic field
that's what we can be clear
we didn't pull this out of our ass if
you remember your your body what do you
mean
the if you remember your periodic table
of elements hydrogen is if it's a full
fleshed out table hydrogen appears twice
once in the upper left and once in the
upper right once in the upper left is
hanging out with the the metals and in
the upper right it's hanging out with
the gases and if I remember that
correctly Charles is that right it
should be written that way yes written
that way and I said why is it twice and
somebody said well sometimes it's
metallic it's a freaking gas what the
hell are you talking about later I'm I
would learn Under Pressure behaves just
like a metal does just like iron and so
yeah so it doesn't have an iron core but
it's got a metallic hydrogen core under
all that pressure for sure and there it
is running the running the Dynamo uh on
Jupiter rather ferocious one at that yes
oh yeah look at that that was good we
got one more in there quick one Pim
bileck
I was wondering what you think is the
biggest obstacle for developing working
warp drive and would you see this
becoming a reality and if yes when
curious about Charles theoretical view
on this oh impatient yeah patreon member
all right so him here's the answer
Charles has already built a warp engine
in his basement
and he can't tell you when it's going to
be released because you know that's
classified information the 1.3 gigawatts
[Laughter]
the thing that is most blocking our
ability to create create a warp drive
quickly is physics
the actual ability to travel faster than
light at this point
through the universe that we have right
now uh we don't have it we don't have
that ability so you have to find a way
to travel through space but not in the
way that everything else travels through
space
so can we actually do what the Star Trek
folks are thinking or Miguel and kubiere
said where you create a Subspace field
and you put yourself inside a warp
bubble which can travel through space
faster than time because the warp bubble
can you can't right or is it some other
way where you actually have to exit our
three dimensions uh and go into a fourth
spatial Dimension and then come back in
these are the questions the basic
fundamental physics are still Beyond us
we can imagine uh we can have fun with
it when we're going to have it
next Wednesday next Wednesday at 3 pm
according to according to reliable
sources the date is April 5th 2063. that
is according to Star Trek first Contact
the movie where uh Picard
he's going to go back from Cochrane in
Montana the one who invented the drive
that event happened on April 5th 2063.
okay well there it is then we got it wow
I gotta tell you that was amazing
reality imitating uh art and yeah make
that happen all right I'm looking back
so I might I'm gonna put that in my
calendar right now right when we're done
here we will party
all right Charles always good to have
you man thanks so much all right love to
the family and you Chuck Nice always
good to have you there Gary we're all in
here all right the pleasure to start
talk sports edition Cosmic queries grab
bag that's like the randomness fun
anyone can ever have
yeah all right Neil deGrasse Tyson here
thanks for listening and as always keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]